ça
imaginez ça cet été sur un pédalo
elle va être très très fort avec des des
squelettes aux pieds c'est les
chaussures là les squelettes en
plastique
quoi parce qu'on dirait des chaussures
de squelettes
[Rires]
j'ai perdu mon frère je n'ai jamais plus
remis les méduses c'est quoi cette race
là tu avais ça au pied comment tu vas
les chiner une meuf avec des méduses non
mais sans déconner tu dois une meuf et
commencer
et alors ça fait longtemps que tu es là
un petit peu dans l'eau
mes frères mais c'est impossible c'est
comme moi une meuf qui a des chaussures
vous savez pas là les chaussures avec
les trucs là sur la tête de ma mère ça
peut être la meuf la plus fraîche du
monde
laisse-moi tranquille laisse-moi
tranquille laisse-moi tranquille
mais quel genre ça fait saucisson on
fait les nœuds et tout on est là
dans ta vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a énormément de bikini qui claque
des dents
quand il arrive à la piscine je suis sur
la tête de ma mère la dame elle arrive
je peux tenir que
incroyable en maillot c'est un des plus
beaux que j'ai vu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous le dis cet été je le dis pour
tous les gars qui sont là c'est le slip
dedans
tu t'es bien bronzé blanc blanc
rajouter une canette de coca
merci
qui va avec bien sûr si il y a rien dans
le bordel voilà
[Rires]
alors tu viens
c'est bien simple les gars j'arrête les
combats terminé rideau on arrête tout
c'est fini
[Rires]
cet été je te veux comme ça j'en ai un
jaune moi jaune
tu vas faire fureur ça c'est sûr tu
crois que kimonoz à la mycolo je peux
l'avoir jusqu'à l'os
pas avec ton petit style toi je vais
dire tu fais touriste allemand en
vacances
[Rires]
il fait touriste allemand il a plus qu'à
mettre la banane autour de la taille
quand même hein
[Rires]
et c'est le seul gars comme les
Allemands il a un short il a un maillot
adidas
avec des chevaux et tu sais pas il a dit
il a des bretzels dans les chapeaux il a
un mousquet toi tu fais touriste
allemand mais moi je souffre du syndrome
du gras double et en fait quand je mets
je mets un slip devant un caleçon j'ai
le bout qui se retourne c'est que vous
avez un gros bide ah ouais le bout qui
se retourne un bout de quoi le bout le
bout du caleçon si vous avez un gros
bide
c'est une galère tu donnes extrêmement
envie à noter les spectateurs qui nous
regardent non vraiment
ça se voit que tu l'as pas vu tout nu
mais vous voyez tous vos copains tout
nus du coup le sol qui est beau gosse
ici il faut arrêter c'est Hugo là c'est
dégueulasse voilà on va pas se mentir
franchement toi tu mets quoi comme
maillot je suis sûr que tu mets des
trucs
[Applaudissements]
rayon comme lui en sonnerie portable
[Rires]
Georges Brassens
on voit pas les couches ah ouais non non
mais arrête
je le dis je passerai trois jours avec
toi trois jours je rigole pas ça pas
plus mais si tu commences par trois
jours tu vas faire la semaine entière
alors par contre tu sais que je suis
hétéro oui bon on le laisse jusqu'à
preuve du contraire oui
aucune preuve de confiance on va dire
hétéro curieux
la curiosité c'est pas du tout mon bail
je te le donne tout peut changer c'est
un autre c'est une bulle dans ta vie qui
sera complètement différente de tout le
reste annule les vacances